[Musique]
ça y est c'est l'été et pour ceux qui
auraient oublié ou pas pris le temps de
préparer leur summer body pour frimer
sur la plage ne vous inquiétez pas notre
dose de les débats sûrement vous
intéresser car entre les jeunes
intermittents les régimes hyperprotéinés
où la fameuse méthode kétou il est
parfois difficile de faire un choix
quand on veut perdre un petit peu de
poids ce serait la solution promet
gaillard sans frustration en france plus
de 50 % des plus de 55 ans avoue avoir
déjà fait un régime mais qu'il est le
régime idéal est le plus adapté pour
vous qu'est-ce qu'on peut encore manger
si on prend quelques exemples régime
baby food va consister à ne manger que
des petits pots de bébé pendant une à
deux semaines le régime hôtesse de l'air
lui promet de perdre jusqu'à 4 kg en
quatre jours l'important c'est de savoir
à quel régime vous allez vous tenir et
surtout de ne pas faire n'importe quoi
ce soit le dr jean michel cohen était
avec nous il va nous donner les
meilleurs conseils pour garder la
silhouette cet été
j'appelle ici on changeait tous
excellents livres et est malin docteur a
justement été les salades méditerranée a
bien souri alors sa queue alors
attention docteur lê d'accord c'est pas
parce qu'elle moss à l'ap que c'est
forcément diététique non mais moi je les
a là deux bergers c'est un adepte de
terre avec l'huile d'olive et tout ça et
le ton et tout ça c'est pas ou feint
donc faire attention non mais là je
t'assure que ça marche ça marche ouais
c'est des salades commence à la de noces
et des salades ou tu donnes du goût à la
salade parce que ce qui manque dans la
nourriture la plupart du temps quand on
fait un régime c'est que c'est pas
agréable à manger donc il faut trouver
du goût avec des épices des herbes et en
méditerranée tout le pourtour du bassin
méditerranéen
bientôt les épiceries mais c'est
toujours lui de lille toujours alors
l'huile d'olive c'est ce qui donne le
plus de goût mais tu peux mettre
d'autres doses huile si tu as envie de
la meilleure des huit c'est l'huile de
colza et du combiné après l'huile
d'olive c'est celle qui a du goût et
ensuite si tu as un peu les moyens tu
t'achètes des huiles un peu exotique
genre l'huile de sésame ça donne une
petite teinte asiatique c'est comme ça
qu'on fabrique une bonne salade très
bien la wii alors ben lala com cdt yade
tout moore sur ces régimes alors le
régime quête aux catégories régime c'est
une méthode attention est alors bruce et
une alimentation c'est un an plus tôt
alors moi je vous résume ce qu'on m'a
dit soit dans une quête au sais tu
manges du gras du gras du gras du gras
et en sucre alors commencer alors
pourquoi ça marche c'est parce que quand
tu manges beaucoup de grave en fait ça
sature l'appétit des gens se terrent
qu'ils atteignent plus rapidement la
société et quand tu manges aussi des
protéines parce que tu manges que des
restes et des protéines et très peu de
légumes parce qu'il faut très peu de
sucre alors à ce moment là ton appétit
est coupée ce qui va se passer c'est que
finalement tu vas réduire
considérablement son apport énergétique
et les gens finissent par manger ce
qu'ils mangeaient 2000 2500 calories par
jour ils finiront par manger mille
quatre cent mille 500 calories par jour
ils vont maigrir il fait maigrir ça
c'est certain il est un peu affaibli
sans qu'on n'y a pas de glucides le
muscler un peu fatigué le cerveau de
marche moins bien
mais après derrière la difficulté comme
dans tous les régimes de te dire plein
de trucs qui font maigrir le jeune fait
maigrir pas manger fait maigrir c'est
derrière quant à manger que des graisses
et que des protéines derrière comment tu
fais quand il ya un copain si tu vas
manger avec gilles tu l'a tapé une pizza
quand tu fais
un
malheur donc alors le régime donc cette
méthode fonctionne mais derrière on
reprend très vite alors on l'a conseillé
le seul endroit où on a conseillé où on
pense que ça pourrait être efficace
c'est pour les gens qui sont épileptique
on a remarqué qu'ils avaient moins de
crises d'épilepsie quand il faisait ce
type de religieux moi je ne conseille
pas parce que derrière il peut y avoir
des problèmes de reins et d'ailleurs des
problèmes de constipation et la
réadaptation à une alimentation normale
est très difficile donc encore une fois
je répète on peut maigrir les pleins de
choses mais derrière comment on fait
quoi alors c'est quoi le régime thonon
alors régime thonon c'est vieux mais
c'est très vieux sa date des années 70
par calorique est hyper côté ça c'est le
régime le régime gehrig et c'est là que
tu vas manger 100 et 500 calories par
jour tu vas manger des yeux avec de la
salade 108 le soir tu auras que du
poulet comme tous les régimes on va
abaisser les sucres et les graisses on
va monter un peu les protéines donc les
gens qui vont ça ce sont des guerrières
400 500 calories par jour tu mets grille
alors pas dans les résultats qui disent
ils disent que les hommes ils peuvent
perdre 10 kilos en deux semaines ses
phobies kg j'aimerais jean-christophe un
type qui fait un mètre quatre-vingt-dix
140 kg qui mangent énormément qu'un
régime ne peut faire maigrir de dikhil
en quinze jours le maximum qu'on peut
avoir à la diète ses sept kilos en
quinze jours après sinon c'est un lit
mais avec lequel on te prives ans à mort
tu vas perdre trois kilos dans la
semaine et peut-être quatre kilos bout
de deux semaines et derrière le problème
c'est que si tu repasses pas par des
paliers successifs tous les reprend en
quelques jours quelques semaines voire
ces vieux ainsi jean-michel dis pas que
dire d'un kilo de graisse est encore
correspond à dix mille calories ben tu
fais le compte c'est 1000 grammes de
graisse ses neuf mille calories oui
c'est exact c'est si on me perdre un
kilo de graisse faut créer un déficit de
10 mille calories mais c'est pour ça que
c'est long c'est chiant c'est non j'ai
expliqué en permanence que pour
commencer à maigrir faut avoir un
décalage de 500 calories par rapport à
sa nourriture d'avant mais quand tu es
500 calories pour avoir dix mille
calories faut une vingtaine de jours
alors heureusement la grèce accompagnée
d'un peu de flotte d'un peu de muscle
donc les gens perdent la bonne cadence
de perte de poids ces 3 5 kilos par mois
dès que tu perds au delà sadique 100
grammes par jour ouais mais dès que tu
perds au delà de son c'est difficile et
derrien encore une fois le régime c'est
le meilleur moment où tu peut
réapprendre à manger aux gens c'est pour
ça qu'on se bat depuis des années pour
faire des régimes équilibrer les régimes
équilibrés sont pas des c'est vraiment
équilibré d'ailleurs parce que tous les
régimes sont forcément plus riche en
protéines moins riches en graisses moins
riches en sucre mais au moins tu
réapprend aux gens à manger un peu de
végétal un peu de deux protéines un peu
de fruits un peu de produits laitiers
mais tu l'aies réadapte quoi si tu fais
pas ce travail là bas c'est le régime
yoyo et c'est les prises perte de poids
puis sur prise de poids c'est quoi la
ville hôtesse de l'air ça c'est alors ça
c'est des trucs de conditionnement c'est
un peu comme les patchs pour maigrir la
fameuse culotte de nabila pour perdre
deux de l'eau c'est des trucs de
conditionnement ça veut dire c'est du
conditionnement autrement dit tu vas tu
appuyé sur une espèce de gris gris pour
te dire que tu vas maigrir le but du jeu
tu manges d'impôt de bb1 peau de bébé
130 grammes ces ententes 1600 pandy par
l'ours à fait inquiets de 300 en fait la
nourriture d'un individu c'est entre
deux kilos de guinot cinq par jour
nocture réduit ton alimentation mais en
faisant ça tu t'appuies sur un système
placebo et toute personne qui décide de
faire ses valises c'est le baby foot ça
ouais c'est ça tu as parlé de quoi de
dire j'aime hôtesse de l'air a baissé sa
mère moi que moi qui ai mon âme et non
le régime hôtesses d'heure c'est un
régime très dur comparable origine tout
non sérieux tu manges très peu mais en
fait à chaque fois tu réduite et apports
énergétiques un homme doit manger grosso
modo de 2400 calories par jour une femme
2006 manche 500 bon tu es fatigué tu
mérites ta costumé gris de six bogeys d
épouser mon fils la gzale est un mélange
de bovins et pipo l'a2 pomme poire
carotte tout ça si je m'en charge mais
non je te connais amuse-toi mettre un
blinis dans un petit pot
c'est ça cc c'est pas le bon en fait
c'est comment fait on réduit les
calories on va pas se mentir mais moi
j'aime ma vie est un élan brégi mais on
m'a appris une chose simple et que le
corps doit maintenir un gramme de sucre
par litre de sang en gros voilà ça c'est
ce qu'a fait le taux de glycémie si on
ne joue pas sur ça on ne peut jamais
maigrir c'est vrai c'est exactement ça
tu as raison c'est est obligé d'avoir
des équilibres dans le corps et c'est
pour ça aussi que quand on maigrit mal
on maigrit pense silhouette il ya des
gens qui disent je comprends pas je
mange beaucoup je maigris pas je perd
patience mais je change de taille en
fait le but en régime c'est de perdre de
la graisse c'est pas de perdre du poids
sur la balance ça signifie rien
d'ailleurs si je mets 2 kg de bouteilles
d'eau minérale sur moi je pèse 2 kg de
plus il faudrait que je pèse 2 kg - ça
ça compte pas ce qui fait plaisir aux
gens c'est de changer de silhouettes
avoir ne vendent pas avoir de deux
poignées d'amour pas avoir de fès faveur
du oui c'est ça qu'ils veulent les gens
donc aplomb sans signe du poids ce qui
compte c'est changer c'est modifier la
teneur le vieil adage les mus pèse plus
lourd que la grèce ça c'est pas fort
c'est pour dire c'est qu'elles sont se
rassurer sa fin nous irons
mon coach de gym il fait un mètre 85 qui
fait 110 kg hakim est taillée mais c'est
magnifique tu prends quelqu'un d'autre
un mètre quatre vingt cinq cent dix
kilos ça déborde de tous les côtés le
muscle c'est une fibre est à l'intérieur
de la fibre il ya de l'eau ça veut dire
que comme tu fait beaucoup de
musculation tu allonge la fibre est donc
à l'intérieur il va y avoir de l'eau et
c'est pour ça que quand on fait de la
musculation de la gymnastique on prend
du poids mais c'est du faux poids
d'ailleurs les gens prennent du poids
mais ils maigrissent quand même c'est en
silhouette donc c'est pour ça qu'on doit
nourrir le muscle et nourrir le muscle
c'est pas que les protéines il faut un
peu de sucres lents à l'intérieur ce
n'est pas de sucres lents tu nourris pas
le melon rires il bat les riz et les
pâtes riz semoule pomme de terre fait qu
une légumineuse voilà légumineuses très
à la mode en ce moment est ce que les
pommes de terre vapeur c'est très bon
c'est mieux les pommes de terre vapeur
que la purée parce que quand tu fais de
la purée tu écrases la bonne de terre
donc tu vas du beurre engagé un peu
ça c'est que les mecs qui disent ça nous
sommes en jeu sans rien c'est quoi la
deuxième four kings ok bah c'est un peu
comme tout à l'heure c'est à dire tu vas
tu appuyé sur un juriste en chef alors
évidemment manger une soupe avec la
fourchette c'est pas évident a donc
enfin son jeu même de dire c'est même
que les modèles je vais prendre la
fourchette est donc tu vas comme tu peux
pas tout manger battu mange pas mais bon
dans ces trucs là il ya les tricheurs
c'est un mec qui va manger avec un
procède par un repas qui va aller dans
le placard il va se prendre un petit
gâteau au chocolat un truc comme ça donc
c'est un conditionnement je me dis je
vais manger qu'avec une pochette donc je
m'interdis tout un tas de l'aliment tu
peux pas manger une entrecôte avec une
fourchette sauf si tu l'a tabassée alors
quoi
la claque rhône chrononutrition c'est ça
c'est une embrouille
il faut le dire c'est un randonnée on te
raconte que si tu manges beaucoup le
matin un peu le midi on allait tous les
soirs et comment malgré un prince à
médire
tapas fin le matin évidemment tu vas
manger beaucoup de maintenant et tu vas
pas manger et deuxièmement en fait ça
marche pas comme ça la nutrition c'est
ce que tu manges sur la journée sur
plusieurs jours sur la semaine qui
conditionnent en fait ce que tu es ça
veut dire tu peux manger très peu une
journée et pas du lait et beaucoup le
lendemain en fait c'est l'équilibré 2
qui est important donc la
chrononutrition ça résonnait sur le fait
que les hormones changerait
l'assimilation des immenses a été testé
deux fois une fois par une équipe
marocaine une fois par une équipe
canadienne 0 résultats mais là on
fonctionne toujours son principe du
conditionnement
c'est à dire je vais me conditionner et
finalement je vais changer ma nourriture
j'ai changé mes repas et aux hôtes au
final je mangerai - on a eu des
problèmes avec ce régime parce que
notamment il y avait des gens qui
conseille de manger énormément de
fromage le matin et là on avait bien
être bouffé de cholestérol
les questions oui oui alors qu'elle est
là la meilleure ou la bonne méthode
qu'il n'ya pas il ya la seule méthode
qui fonctionne c'est la réduction de thé
apport énergétique la réduction du
nombre de calories que tu manges dans la
journée suffisamment pour perdre du
poids en sachant qu'au bout d'un moment
tu vas être rattrapé parce que quand tu
vas à maigrir quand a par exemple perdu
20 kilos tu dépenses pas pareil qu'avant
il faudra encore réduire la nourriture
donc ça veut dire un il faut avoir une
vraie motivation pas se dire tiens je
mets bien parce que c'est le moment de
maigrir de il faut éliminer tous les
facteurs psychologiques ces sites est
dépressif si tu as des soucis site est
en galère tu peux pas faire ça à 3 faut
pas prendre de médicaments associés il
ya aucun médicament qui fait maigrir
aucun tout les trucs qu'on vous vend à
droite à gauche c'est pour vous piquer
un peu de pognon c'est un médicament
honneur tout ça les boules
c'est bien enfin quand même mais ça ça
fonctionne parce qu'il ya des petits
complet c'est le cycliste ça fait des
compléments alimentaires et en fait ça
te coupe la faim qui il ya deux choses
il ya les produits naturels dedans et
après il ya aussi d autres comprimés qui
permettent de drainer deux augmenté la
chaleur un peu du corps de quelqu'un de
généreux thermogénèse et du coup on ça
sèche alors je suis très bien à quel
moment ça le foot si tu connais la
prière il faut faire avec
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la technique des sportifs de haut niveau
par exemple c'est de boire 2 3 grand
verre d'eau avant le repas parce que ça
remplit l'estomac et du coup on mange
plus on fonce à tous les repas est ce
que ça c'est sympa ça marche mais c'est
assez éphémère ça veut dire c'est un peu
comme le truc qui est à la mode les
gélules de congés ou les
paddocks un produit qui absorbe de l'eau
qui remplissent ton estomac et ça donne
une sensation de satiété le problème de
l'eau c'est qu'une fois que tu l'as
absorbé elle passe assez rapidement dans
l'intestin donc ça peut te servir sur
les premiers instants du repas c'est
aussi un site à mai mais ça au moins
c'est ainsi même pas dangereux tu
comprends donc ça tout ce qui est pas
dangereux et qui fait du bien aux quais
même si c'est bullshit ça on le
sait j'ai pas beaucoup de questions moi
que je veux en venir à ma femme ma vie
mais oui on est amis j'en ai moi même ma
fameuse méthode qu'eto'o est ce qu'avec
par exemple ils peuvent rappel vous
mangez du grand du grac du grand nom
s'est pas que du gras c'est du gras très
peu de sucre et on a droit quand même à
ras du grain la protéine aussi on a
droit de la potée est ce qu'il y aurait
quelque chose parce qu'il ya aussi le
régime low carb qui permet de manger
même chose non mais ça mange ton pote on
s'appelle l'engin petit peu plus s'ils
créent quelques elle se rêve pour moi le
régime idéal si je veux continuer à
supprimer de ses sucres si tu as aimé te
guérir
[Rires]
si tu as réussi à maigrir avec n'importe
quel régime c'est pas du tout important
c'est pas grave derrière il va falloir
réadapter ton alimentation c'est à moi
ce que je donne dans ces cas là c'est
des régimes autour de 1500 calories par
jour bien équilibrée te forcer à faire
puis monter progressivement à près de
1500 passé à 1700 puis à 2000
des kills au chant michel jeunesse et ça
c'est la peur des gens chaque fois
qu'ils ont tous fait d'arrêter à se
reprendre de ça on a tout ça le fond et
demi le poids idéal est en fait c'est un
jamais c'est comment on se sent bien
l'idéal c'est quand tu te regarde dans
la glace et des contours bien alors il
va donner un conseil de docteur cohen et
ses ingrédients n'oubliez pas ce que
c'est c'est un peu on fait ça tous le
matins on prend tous un jus d'orange
c'est la pire des choses
à vous dire pourquoi la tempête quand
vous prenez un jus d'orange ii matin en
fait ça vous donne un pic de sucre à
l'étain sur in et s'avoue nick toute la
journée
c'est vrai alors un des ja qui en est
proche du danger si on peut pas s'en
passer il faut le prendre avec la pulpe
au moyen des fibres ça aidera la
direction du suc sinon si c'est du jus
industriels c'est vraiment comme si tu
prenais des carrés de succès ces deux
quarts et demi par verre en moyenne donc
ça donne un pic de sucre dans le sang et
j'avais expliqué aux gens qui avaient un
truc qui marchait très bien tu prends un
comprimés de vitamine c alors en jeu sud
mais dans un verre d'eau si tu viens du
faux sucre si tu veux à l'intérieur ça
te donnera le même effet au moins deux
tours a pas les calories du sud donc
l'idée du jus d'orange qui met en forme
les gens maintenant c'est dans la tête
la vitamine c il n'y a pas de carence en
france la carence en vitamine c c'est le
scorbut vous avez déjà vu ça en france
jamais donc voilà il faut 100 mg de
vitamine c par jour pour un homme c'est
dans tout ce qu'on demande ont conversé
docteur
voilà élevé le bon point comment se sent
bien et puis la force